Hello?
Hey, Amanda.
How are you?
Not so good.
Why not?
What happened?
We had a big storm last night and my house is damaged badly.
Oh my god.
Are you and your family okay?
We are all right but there are things that need to be fixed.
It must have been a really huge storm.
Yes, it was.
All the windows are broken, first of all.
Every single one of them?
Yes.
Second, the roof is leaking and the wall is cracked.
Oh my god.
That's worse than I expected.
We had a blackout for the past eight hours.
I'm so sorry to hear that.
Did you call up a repair person?
Yes.
He's looking around the house right now.
Hope everything turns out okay.
Oh my goodness!
What?
The pipes are broken!
Okay.
Why don't we stop our lesson here?
Call a plumber right now.